going further together the aging
population Europeans are living longer
than ever before but they are also
having fewer children so over the coming
decades the proportion of retired and
elderly people will increase at the same
time the proportion of people of working
age will fall by 2060 there will only be
two workers for every person aged 65 or
over
half as many as today although
emigration to give a helping hand
populations in about half that EU member
states are expected to shrink the total
population of the EU will only grow
slightly before peaking in 2050 these
changes will have profound consequences
for our society and for public spending
particularly on pensions and health care
public expenditure on health and long
term care is expected to rise by two
percentage points of gross domestic
product by 2060 at the same time there
will be fewer workers paying taxes and
increasing demands on public expenditure
now is the time to take the big
decisions to prepare for our future
governments will need to continue
reforming their health care and pension
systems and the European Commission is
helping them by providing objective
policy advice
but since more demand is placed on a
health and long term care services they
need to be managed more efficiently so
everyone can enjoy dignity and security
throughout their lives as life
expectancies lengthen people should
expect to extend their working lives and
rescale to keep on contributing to our
economic growth everyone young and old
needs to work together to secure a
sustainable economic future the European
economy stronger together
you